[Musica]
quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare a
questo Ted X ho detto
Che bello il
X tutti quanti conoscevamo il Ted x No
cioè nel senso io lo conoscevo cioè
sapevo tutto è quel posto dove è divisa
vive sul palco e devi
devi dire le cose cioè no devi fa tipo
un monologo anche nomo c'è anche suonare
un dialogo No vabbè devi salire sul
palco e dire qualcosa di sensato e già
qui
sto partendo ma Ah poi me l'ho detto che
doveva durare
18 minuti al massimo è già qui un altro
problema perché non so se si è notato ma
io mi dilungo molto quando parlo
e poi mi hanno detto che dovevo parlare
dello Straordinario
lo straordinario
Ma in che senso
io non ho il panico così sono andata a
cercare sul dizionario che cos'è lo
straordinario Vabbè Cito Eh dice sì
straordinario eccedente limiti del
normale o del comune con significati che
si determinano nel senso di
un'eccezionalità rispetto alla prassi o
all'ordine consueto
chiaro no Avete capito Vabbè dai
straordinario lo dice stesso la parola
straordinario non ordinario non normale
In effetti io tutta la vita ho cercato
qualcosa di straordinario perché nella
mia vita è sempre stato tutto molto
normale
partendo anche dal mio aspetto io non
sono né alta né bassa sono normale non
sono bellissima ma non sono manco
bruttissime sono normale a scuola non
ero bravissimo ma non ero nemmeno un
somaro era normale
i miei capelli non sono Biondi morì cioè
il colore è normale pure i miei genitori
no fanno tutti quanti tutti e due tutti
quanti tutti e due quanti ne ho fanno un
lavoro normale
Io ho sempre vissuto in questa bolla di
normalità e quindi per tutta la vita ho
cercato qualcosa di straordinario
a una certa mi sono fatta pure bionda
ecco
ora riguardo quelle foto Mi chiedo ma
perché Ah poi a 23 anni ho deciso che la
palestra era troppo ordinaria come sport
mi sono iscritta a cerchio aereo
Quello sì che è uno sport straordinario
volteggiare con una farfalla nell'aria
mi sono rotto il polso dopo due mesi che
ho iniziato però cioè io continuo Eh non
demordo
In realtà io fin da piccola volevo fare
l'attrice Quello sì che è un mestiere
straordinario Ho fatto tanti corsi di
recitazione ho partecipato a tantissimi
spettacoli teatrali anche amatoriali
Però fino a 20 anni io venivo solo
sfruttata e così persi coraggio e mi
sono iscritta all'università Però anche
lì niente di eccezionale era un piano B
non lo volevo fare veramente non avevo
voti alti o voti bassi avevo voti
normali
Poi però qualcosa di straordinario
l'ho fatto
ho pubblicato il mio primo video su
Facebook
non ho un video sensato Eh no
video con l'evidenziatori in testa Ecco
Vabbè Quella era la mia vita ai tempi io
facevo video sull'università perché
facevo l'università e così
all'improvviso ho iniziato ad avere i
miei primi fan
io
i fan Quello sì che qualcosa di
straordinario poi dopo ho smesso di fare
video con gli evidenziatori in testa eh
adesso Faccio certi video che cioè va
una carriera sui social che
tutto cima Sì però se avevo i fan Quello
sì che straordinario cioè gli unici fan
che avevo fin da piccola erano i miei
genitori che quando recitavo la poesia a
Natale malissimo Mi dicevano Brava brava
amore tu un giorno farai l'attrice Ecco
se io da piccola volevo fare l'attrice è
colpa loro oppure quando io tipo facevo
uno scarabocchio io davo Come disegno
Brava amore tu sarai il nuovo Giotto
falsi
Ecco avere dei fan È simile solo che
straordinario persone che non ti
conoscono che ti seguono apprezzano
quello che fai tu quando fai stronzate
senza senso
e quando hai dei fan succedono delle
cose straordinarie una dietro l'altra
fai lo spettacolo che hai sempre sognato
va in tour nei teatri più importanti
d'Italia
Vai agli eventi dove possono entrare
soltanto persone selezionate
ti chiedono le foto per strada a me le
foto
poi la fai Red Carpet fai questi Red
Carpet meravigliosi con questi abiti
stupendi esce la sua foto sul giornale
non è nemmeno un imperfezione sul viso
non è nemmeno un poro un brutto non è
nemmeno la pelle
bellissimo Quello sì che è straordinario
Però io tornavo a casa dopo tutte queste
cose straordinarie mi toglievo il
vestito piano perché devi riconsegnarlo
eh
mi mettevo il mio pigiama party sesso
e non mi sentivo straordinaria per
niente
mi sentivo la solita ragazza ordinaria
con la mamma ordinaria che mi chiede se
ho fame
mio papà che lavora all'agenzia delle
entrate ordinario il mio fidanzato
ordinario che dice che passo troppo
tempo in bagno la mia nonna ordinaria
che mi vede sciupata e le mie ordinarie
insicurezze che
mi dicono ogni giorno che tutte queste
cose straordinarie io non me le merito
per niente
io
tornavo a casa
e mi sentivo svuotata
inutile
però in quei momenti succedeva qualcosa
di particolare
io mi sentivo vuota ma non ero sola
c'era sempre qualcuno accanto a me ma
quello che mi voleva bene che mi faceva
sentire nel posto giusto che mi
preparava una cioccolata calda
chi mi diceva che andava tutto bene ecco
questa noi la chiamiamo normalità
Ma è una fortuna
io galleggiando in questa ordinarietà ho
imparato ad apprezzarla e ho imparato a
capire che non è scontata
belli fan bello i tour
belli gli spettacoli film Io mi auguro
che questa vita possa durare a lungo
ma sono le piccole cose quelle che noi
che diciamo che sono normali e sono
speciali la routine la semplice routine
stare sul divano a guardare una serie TV
la skincare prima di andare a dormire
avere una casa avere un letto dove
dormire
quello è straordinario ora preparatevi
perché sto per dire qualcosa che
veramente banale eh scontata come i
piumini a marzo di Zara
è la normalità la cosa straordinaria
Lo so lo so
L'ha detto Lucio Dalla Ben prima di me
l'impresa eccezionale Dammi retta È
essere normale
certo lui ha detto meglio però lui era
un artista straordinario Io no Io sono
un artista ordinario e vi giuro che va
benissimo così
[Musica]